foreign
how can we help
hello thank you for taking my calls you
bet
uh you know I just have a quick question
with you know I just I'm using some debt
and I just feel like at the end of the
mom at the end of paying everything I
just had no money for myself and you
know I'm slowly paying it off and doing
OT it's not like I'm just doing my
quality and going home it's just kind of
like I'm putting in you know 32 hours of
open every two weeks you know I just
feel like I never have enough money
okay how do you know if you I just need
some advice or some help sure well let's
first start with asking you what's your
what's your budgeting process like do
you budget at all
yes I actually did start last month um I
took the whole month of June to kind of
just see what I spend my money on and
I've noticed I spent a lot of money on
food like just eating out and
um one good side about that of doing
that is now I know I spend it on that so
now I'm not being more conscious do so
you've only done this one month so let
me start by saying
we've told people for decades it takes
about 90 days three months or so to just
figure this thing out so give yourself
some Grace as you're heading into month
two but what you're focusing on is how
much am I short do you have an idea how
short you are right now at the end of
the month I feel like well usually I'm
never really sure it's just kind of like
at the end it's kind of just like I'll
have like two three four hundred dollars
to like for myself because I can spend
on whatever I want and I usually just
end up putting that in a savings and
then kind of just like living what like
two hundred dollars
so what do you know after your first
month of budgeting that where there's a
lot of fat that you can trim off we've
already identified one which is eating
out what else where else are you
spending a lot of money that you don't
need to spend it
um probably going out as well is this
food like food eating out at work trying
to find some food and then going out
like on the weekend all right what's the
combined number that you spent last
month just ballpark figure on going out
uh and eating out
um from probably about
uh let's see
probably last month about like six seven
hundred dollars all right so there's a
six to seven hundred dollar difference
right there if you begin to cut that and
you get disciplined you understand what
I'm saying so now you want to cut back
for a month in month number two of
budgeting and then look for other
expenses that you can cut and go okay
can I find and I'm just making this up
right now but you've got it could I find
an additional thousand dollars a month
right now do you have any debt
I do so I mean it's kind of weird so
um
about a year ago actually a year ago we
met in a couple of days I broke my ankle
and I was working as a manager of
security and then they laid me off the
contract ended so they wanted to give
you another job that was very relaxing
payment you got through offering in the
teams when I was getting up to cool for
30. so I you know decided just to take
some time off and
find a new job that wasn't security I
found a new job and then I broke my
ankle again I was probably out of work
for about six seven months and then in
that time I amassed about you know
twelve thousand dollars in debt and then
another like two thousand dollars in
credit card debt so as you Consolidated
the 12 000. okay so the only debt you
have is twelve thousand dollars it's
been Consolidated recently is that what
I'm hearing yes and what's that yeah 12
000 in a consolidated loan about two
thousand dollars in credit card and then
I have a mortgage
okay so you're familiar with our baby
steps yes
yeah okay so where are you on the I know
you're trying to budget and the
budgeting is a learning process while
we're attacking the debt so do you have
a thousand dollars in your emergency
fund
baby step one
uh yeah well tell me when tomorrow I get
paid so I know I've done so this you
know last week I did about 35 hours of
overtime so I can just pay off the
here's my credit card you're not
answering my question my friend baby
step one is one thousand dollars in the
savings account for an emergency do you
have that right now
yes you have a thousand dollars
yes in savings
yes not more just a thousand
yes I have a thousand dollars in my
savings account all right my regular
checkings account okay so the baby steps
now you've got baby step one done now
we're taking the smallest debt you have
and we're gonna attack that with
everything you have the budgeting
process that we just walked through is
to find as much money as possible that
you can attack the debt snowball with so
the smallest debt is what you're going
after next and then if you knock when
you knock that out you take what you
have been paying towards that and you
put it towards the next one and you just
keep working through this process do you
understand what I'm saying
yeah that's what's next for you
I okay what do you do for a living man
well I'm a ranger at the moment so I
work for um Commonwealth
arranger is that a park ranger or a
police officer yeah
park ranger okay
um do you live on site do you live on at
a camp or do you live at home
no I live at home it's about 15 minutes
away so I take the public transportation
I don't own a car uh that's good news
okay I was going to suggest you uh pick
up a second and third job
um and begin figuring out ways but
you're working overtime so much here's
what I think you got to do man you got
you got to get radical
the way Dave says it is I will not see
the inside of a restaurant unless I work
at one
I will not go on a date with somebody
unless we are going for a walk in a
beautiful Oregon Park
I'm just not going to spend any money
because I gotta get out from under this
debt
so I can get my life back you don't have
a life right now man you're killing
yourself working overtime just to stay
afloat
all right and we we say it all the time
man you're just worth more of a life
than the one you're leading and so man
keep working overtime but get this stuff
out you don't have a huge amount of debt
um you do live in a state that takes a
big chunk of your paycheck every time
you bring some home so that'll take a
little bit longer than it might in
another state but man I would just keep
hammering it and hammering it and
hammering it and get it get it done
right because I know I mean like I said
I worked a whole bunch of overtime in
the credit card debt by tomorrow when I
get paid it's going to be done so then
the consolidated loan is what's next and
awesome right so so how quickly can you
pay off that twelve thousand if if
you've given everything you got by
cutting all of your expenses that you
can cut I mean you cut everything that
you don't need how quickly could you pay
off the 12 000.
I mean you know I did some math around
it and I think I can get it down
hopefully you know with
with the projected number I have about
probably next summer great no chance you
can get it done faster than that I
absolutely agree but you're gonna have
to work you have to work more so I don't
know if you're if you're changing jobs
you're talking about a year from now you
you how much do you make
I make about 50 000 for my job and then
I have a income home so I have events at
home that I make about an extra 900 a
month
I would sell that rental home you can't
afford it
can you sell that home well the mortgage
is paid and I actually make money from
it oh so you own that Home Free and
Clear
no so I have a mortgage on it but with
the amount of money I get from it the I
pay the mortgage plus I get um payments
towards my pajamas what do you do
tomorrow if the air conditioner goes out
how are you gonna pay for that
that's you know that is where when I
broke my ankle that was where one of the
reasons I had mastered a lot of that no
we're running out of time running out of
time I got to be quick sorry to
interrupt but it's on purpose how much
is that house worth right now if you
sold it today
about 360. what do you owe on it
about 2 30. sell that house today you're
debt free you have a fully funded
emergency fund and you are starting to
pay off your mortgage brother you know
what you'll do on Monday of next week
sleep deeper than you slept in years
you still haven't recovered
psychologically from breaking your ankle
and you're gonna have to forgive
yourself for the seven months where it
was really tough to get up and move
around after that and you just didn't
work and you stayed at home and you dug
yourself a hole let's clear that hole
you're on the right path now brother
you're on the right path stay on the
line I'm going to send you Financial
Peace University and every dollar app
the best app for taking care of your
daily and monthly budget Standalone I'm
gonna give it to you as my gift to send
you onto the right path sell that house
brother and get free